das finde ich halt so geil ich finde
dass es mit das geld sei an dieser
modifikation dass sich quasi wie so ein
ändern wenn wir die ganzen blöcke nehmen
kann einfach auf die blöden verwandten
familie schmeißen kann die alle mega
blöd sind und danach einfach weg
teleportiert werden kann
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
mord vorstellung allerdings ist das
heute ein etwas anderem mord
vorstellungen weil das eine sehr sehr
sehr sehr große modifikation ist und
zwar die newton creatures mod und da
werden halt fünf ganz ganz heftige
kreaturen hinzugefügt als mutant ändern
ist dabei newtons newton zombie newton
skeleton und reaper und wenn ich ich
habe das jetzt mal durchgespielt wenn
ich theoretisch abzielen mob so eine
komplette word seiten notizen wie grad
gemacht und wenn ich das alles
hintereinander vorstellen würde wird das
ganze video vielleicht 40 minuten gehen
und ich werde danach tot wie sonstwas
welches alte forscher müssen deswegen
mache ich das jetzt so dass ich nach und
nach diesem ops vorstellung also fünf
videos daraus mache oder 43 keine ahnung
die anderen wie lange die anderen cops
dann insgesamt gehen aber wahrscheinlich
werden fünf videos wo ich dann in jedem
video dieser einzelne diese einzelnen
mob vorstellen weil es echt immer mega
viel zu sagen gibt zu einem einzelnen
mob und ich hab's allein zum ändern geht
das video denke ich jetzt wahrscheinlich
schon zehn minuten also nicht schon aber
es wird wahrscheinlich zehn minuten oder
so gehen deswegen hoffe ich dass sie das
akzeptiert habe dann die nächsten tage
immer ein paar mehr videos von mir assad
box und ich würde sagen ich fange jetzt
erst mal an mit dem endermann und
außerdem ist der aufbau dieser mod
vorstellen auch ein bisschen anders ich
hoffe euch gefällt viel spaß kommen wir
erst mal ein paar generelle
informationen über den mutant ändern
beziehungsweise über die mod an sich und
zwar fügt diese matte hat verschiedene
ob sich gerade schon gesagt hat hinzu
und zwar fünf verschiedene an der zahl
oder noch so ein paar kleineren
abweichungen von diesem ort sind von
diesem ab sind bleibe glaube das ist
relativ egal aus diesen unwichtig
jedenfalls stelle ich euch jetzt den
mutant endermann vor und die ganzen mops
und außerdem acht minuten ändern spawnen
genauso wie anderem ob es auch also bei
nacht etc blablabla aber viel seltener
der mutant endermann 800 herzen und es
friedlich bis man ihn an guckt also wie
die normale ändern wenn auch nur wenn
man ihn anguckt dann zieht der 1
ein teilweise auch blind auch ein
unterschied zum normalen endermann ist
das wenn man ein kürbis auf hat wird er
böse anstatt dann irgendwie da irgendwie
aufzuhören
und wenn er sich teleportiert scharte
der alle mops um einen herum um zwei
herz und manchmal macht er die auch
blinde gibt diese blindheit effekt den
man dann im inventar sie kommen wir nur
zu ersten attacke dieses mops und zwar
hat dieser mob vier arme und kann damit
halt ganz normal wie normale ende märz
auch natürlich blöcke stehlen allerdings
kann er mich als spieler auch mit diesen
blöcken angreifen aber machen die
inneren arme vier herzen schaden und die
äußere name fünf herzen schaden und er
kann außerdem die gestohlenen blöcke die
da halt einfach so mitnehmen mit seinen
armen so blablabla kann er auf die
spieler drauf werfen und das macht drei
bis vier herzen wir einen direkten
treffer also wenn der spieler den direkt
abbekommt und zwei herzen beim splash
fitter ist als also splash treffer das
ist wenn er den quasi vor einwirft oder
hinter allen oder links rechts neben
einem bekommt man halt nur zwei herzen
schaden kommen wir nun zu klauen taktik
und zwar kann dieser mutant endermann 8
million ändern wenn um einen herum zu
bauen das habe ich schon am anfang
gesagt dass er noch andere mops
hinzugefügt wurden die aber eher
unwichtig sind und nur unter mops bzw
unterkategorien von den eigentlichen
zugefügten mops sind der mutant ändern
ist halt selber getarnt als einer von
diesen acht mutant endemann minion mops
und zwar ist dieser minuten am inhalt
selbst davon getarnt als einer von denen
und ist halt einfach nur ein wenig
größer aber ist quasi genau gleich wie
die während der jugend ändern wenn diese
ganze clown attacke macht greifen die
kleinen minions einen zufällig anderen
zufälligen zeitintervallen das macht
immer 05 herzen schaden und die
teleportieren sich auch zufällig herum
und dass trichet bei der ganzen sache
geht es überhaupt das richtige ich weiß
es gar nicht aber dass tricky dieser
sache ist dass dieser minuten ändern
wenn ja getan ist als einer von den
kleinen minions allerdings macht dieser
mutant endermann drei herzen schaden
und immer wenn er einen drei herzen
schaden macht mit einer attacke wenn er
halt so minion ist dann bekommt er immer
noch ein gehaltes leben dazu also ein
gehaltes herz also diese ganze taktisch
und relativ krass aber wenn man einfach
den newton tender main enttarnt und
zuerst wird also der ist ja ein bisschen
größer als die anderen minions ist die
attacke halt direkt vorbei und kommen
wir nun zur tele smash attacke des
newton länder men und die relativ kurze
klare dazu nicht viel sagen und zwar
keine mio
ändern wenn auch spieler teleportieren
also nicht nur sich selbst und zwar kann
er mich dann einfach niemand in die luft
schleudern so wie auf dem bild sieht was
hier gerade eingeblendet seht und das
macht drei herzen schaden die attacke an
sich dann fliegt man natürlich die luft
dann bekommt man nochmal fall schaden
wenn man bis auf den boden knallt also
das kommt noch dazu kommen wir nun zur
stream attacke des newton tender männer
also zu deutsch übersetzt der schrei
attacken who und zwar ist es auch eine
weitere attacke von ihm und zwar bekommt
der ändern schaden im regen also der
mutant ändern sollte man lieber sagen
weil wir noch mal ändern wenn die
teleportieren sich dann halt nur wieder
umher und damit erhöht sich die chance
dass dieser mutant ändern diese stream
attacke einsetzt also der kann die auch
so einsetzen aber im regen ist die
chance für das er die einsätze der
stream machte er schreit macht zwei
herzen schaden und der schaden durch
dringt auch rüstungen also soll so sein
dass der schrei quasi durch die ohren
reingeht in das gehör und deswegen man
die herzen schaden bekommt deswegen kann
er keine rüstung gegen wirken auch wenn
man theoretisch ohrenschützer haben
sollte außerdem stoppt der regen wänden
regen ist während er die attacke
einsetzt und wenn man ganz viel glück
hat kann man neben diesen herzen keine
weiteren effekte davon erlangen also was
heißt erlangen bekommen sage ich jetzt
mal lieber weil normalerweise bekommt
man auch effekte wie beispielsweise
boysen also eine vergiftung wie es also
schwäche hunger oder noch sie also
übelkeit und wenn man dann ganz viel
pech hat dann kann dieser schreien
erhält auch schon mal töten
apropos töten kommen wir zum tod des
newton ändern und zwar wenn der minuten
tender mensch spielt seine seele
sozusagen instabil und verdirbt mehr
oder weniger
dabei stößt er dann anderson fragment
aus und diese explodieren binnen
sekunden und sprang ein halt weg also
immer so hin und her weil die halt alle
abwechselnden explodieren und die machen
auch ein wenig schaden dabei wenn er
außerdem
außerdem eine stirbt kann man ein
pumpkin dabei auf den kopf setzen und
damit verhindert man halt die wirkung
dieser frequenz und den meisten schaden
als man kann dann halt nicht mehr diesen
ganzen explosions schaden von diesem
komischen fragment star bekommen
außerdem beim tod bekommt man achten
drops also dessen ender perlen und ende
augen die der ender männer halt drop
allerdings noch mehr aber dazu komme ich
erst gleichmann luca du bist so schlau
ich sage einfach dazu komme ich gleich
aber wohl vergessen dass ich hier
mittendrin karte also ja dazu komme ich
jetzt so hey
und zwar gibt es auch noch die ender
soul handy finde ich besonders am als
newton tender mandy ist megageil einfach
nur und zwar während dieser mutant
ändern entsteht kann man die fragmente
die dann herumschwirren rechts klicken
und das muss man halt machen bevor sie
explodieren also bevor die explodieren
einfach rechts drauf machen und dann
noch mal rechts klicken während man es
nicht um sie fallen zu lassen wenn allen
dann nun so ein paar von diesen
fragmenten dann halt folgen dann kann
man einfach ein ende hat auge fallen
lassen also droppen nicht ein ende auge
reicht klickt man wenn man andere rechts
liegt an fliegt das jahr hoch und dann
zeigt dass ein wo nennt ist zeigt ein wo
das endet also einfach fallen lassen und
diese kombination baut einem dann diese
andersson hängt also die eigene
individuelle enders soll herrn für den
spieler diese enders soll hand kann 60
benutzt 60 mal benutzt werden pro enders
soll fragt welches einheit folgt also
wenn zum beispiel ich vier fragment
rechtsklick und dann das ende gefallen
lasse dann habe ich halt viermal 60 sind
240 benutzungen und das ist auch schon
die maximale anzahl an benutzungen also
vier folgende fragment das macht drei
herzen schaden mit der mediothek also
mediathek habe ich schon gesagt das ist
dass mit diesem blöcke wenn ich den
nehme und dann wegschmeißen und zwar
mache ich das mit rechtsklick ich kann
mit recht ich einfach auf einen block
draufsetzen und ihnen einfach
wegschmeißen keine sorge ich gehe gleich
noch in mein eigenes minecraft 1 oder
durch das zeigen wir die ganzen attacken
funktionieren und es sieht doch echt
mega geil aus und außerdem wenn man
rechtsklick macht und dabei sind dann
kann man sich zu einem blog teleportiert
werden also man kann sich selbst einen
blog teleportieren was das wieder ändern
werden das geht im radius von 128
blöcken und dabei attackiert man dann
auch mops in der umgebung also das dann
dieser splash mit mehr oder weniger der
macht dann auch ein bisschen schaden die
anderson verbraucher die enders solvent
verbraucht dabei unter anderem vier
benutzungen anstatt nur eine bei der
mediathek und wenn sie allerdings mal
kaputt gehen sollte bzw fast kaputt ist
und man noch freie enders of frequenz
hinter sich hat beispielsweise läufer
bei sich hat dann kann man einfach die
hand aus dem inventar rausschmeißen also
wieder nicht recht machen weil man ja
wieder sich irgendwie teleportieren
würde oder im blog aufnehmen würde
sondern einfach aus dem inventar
schmeißen und dann repariert die sich
quasi von selbst mit dem benutzungen
jeweils wie viele fragment man noch hat
also wenn ich noch drei fragment haben
hunt hat noch fünf benutzungen dann sind
das drei mal 60 höchstens halt also 60
prozent sind 180 50 haben sind 185
benutzung die ich dann noch habe und ich
würde sagen das ist jetzt erstmal mit
der groben theorie wir sind jetzt schon
so lange am lagern hier wieder dabei
gesagt ich teile das einfach in mehrere
videos ich glaube dass du auch die
richtige entscheidung bei dieser großen
modifikation aber ich würd sagen wir
sehen uns jetzt erstmal im singleplayer
mit der modifikation wieder so freunde
wir befinden uns jetzt hier in meiner
minecraft welt die ich mir vorhin
einfach so generiert habe dies das
anders hab ich überhaupt mehr hab ich
nicht okay gut nochmal gut geschickt und
zwar ist ganz cool dass ihre blätter
dort versucht ein paar mops und es am
start mit denen ich euch gleich diese
attacken mit der enders soul herzeigen
kann die auch megageil eigentlich
aussieht weil sie sich so komisch mal
bewegt so sieht das ganze aus wenn ich
dich in der hand halte das ist quasi
sowie wie heißt der x-men nicht xps oder
sdx men
ich weiß nicht ob diese für mich geguckt
wie dieser typ diese langen daraus hatte
keine ahnung x-men origins ich weiß es
nicht
hättet mich wieder alle dafür dass ich
nicht das nicht weiß jedenfalls ich
würde sagen ich hab ich ja gar schon
alles gesagt wir können es einfach noch
ein bisschen mit diesem newton ändern
ein herum spielzeug ein paar sachen
erstmal so sieht der ganze aus ihr habt
gerade schon ein bisschen die geräusche
von dem gehört die zeigt jetzt noch mal
so also so hörte sich an deshalb relativ
groß
doppelt so groß wie der kleine kong
crafter hier kann ich jetzt einfach ein
bisschen schlagen das ist jetzt habe ich
zum beispiel diese bleiben das bekommen
hier blindheit fünf sekunden kann
herumfliegen sich gar nichts mehr
und jetzt hat er sich weg teleportiert
und jetzt bin ich wieder frei also wenn
ich jetzt mal schlage ich will es mal
ohne die blindheit sehen dass ihr seht
dass er sich weg teleportiert
doch fester ich weiß nicht ob es daran
liegt dass ich gar kein created bin kann
auch sein
jetzt hat er sich gab wechselte portiert
soll es ja hier natürlich richtig gut
weil ich einen stein ich gehe mal ganz
kurz in game mode 0
damit der quasi auf mich fokussiert ist
wenn ich den jetzt angucke ps ach ich
bin auch ich besser ihre gedichte
eingeben gaylord 0
selbst auf mich fokussiert jetzt gehe
ich das mal ganz kurz ein jetzt ist er
nämlich sauer auf mich auch wenn ich
jetzt im gamer anziehen damit ihr mal
sehen wie schnell der cas hatte nämlich
diese clown attacke eingesetzt haben wir
acht von diesen komischen klonen hier
und einer von denen ist der endermann
selbst in dieser hier ist ein bisschen
größer das heißt das hier ist er
oder war das jetzt ich weiß es gar nicht
grüßen der jetzt ein bisschen durch das
jetzt gattin kate bin ja das war und
jetzt habe ich ihn halt getötet diesen
anderen dass der eigentlich er war
deswegen ist jetzt die attacke mehr oder
weniger vorbei so ich kann jetzt noch
weiter schlagen teleportiert der sich
wieder wenn ich ganz nah an ihm dran bin
kann es auch sein dass er teilweise dann
diesen komischen wurf auspackt ich hoffe
das zeigt er uns jetzt mal oder ich gehe
wirklich mal ganz kurz in game mode 0
und bleibe da drin so jetzt hat mich ein
bisschen geboxt haben dem startet jemand
hat er diese blöde ding für mich wieder
gemacht diese clown attacke das ja ich
will euch mal zeigen wie es aussieht
wenn er ein hoch wirft mir was passiert
wenn du mich hoch wer ist mein kleine
schätze gehen wo wir stoppen ob dieser
kompromiss ist die clown attacke und ich
bin der das ist fragt also dass es mir
ganz recht
also setzte mich immer der typ zeig mir
doch mal was passiert wenn du mich hoch
wirfst wenn du mit hoch ist mein
schätzchen jetzt explodiert eine mit
diese ganzen fragmente die ich jetzt
rechts klicken kann bevor sie war
labadee besser auch nein ich hab's euch
nicht hingekriegt hat doch jetzt nicht
immer ganz kurz das haus und setzten
einen kürbis auf auch nicht zu langsam
ich hab's nicht hingekriegt
ich habe es echt nicht hingekriegt doch
da ist noch 11 habe ich alles hinter mir
cook das ist gut weil jetzt kann ich
euch zeigen wie das ist jetzt so ein
blödes fragment hinter mir
na du kleiner pisser jetzt kann ich
einfach so ein ende hinschmeißen und
jetzt habe ich diese ende hängt also ich
habe ja zwei weil naja ihr wisst ihr
bescheid so dieser hat jetzt die hälfte
der leben weil ich irgendwie wohl zwei
hatte ich hatte irgendwie wohl zwei von
diesen fragmenten hinter mir keine
ahnung ob dann noch irgendwo 1 war
jedenfalls hat jetzt die hälfte hier
vorher aufgeladen
dementsprechend die hälfte also 130 130
bildern 120 120 die hälfte wird 204
zählt max im abi alles gut jetzt zur
hälfte aufgeladen und deswegen kann ich
damit jetzt ein paar benutzung machen
ich kann es auf dem blog rechtsklick
machen nochmal recht sekunden netzte dem
blöden slime darauf schmeißen soll der
selbst tod der neun von diesen komischen
herzen schaden gebraucht so ungleich ist
meine haltbarkeit noch ein bisschen
schlecht also sieht dann solle mit
attacke aus wenn ich die quasi hier so
hinsetze so da quasi mann
ich treffe die kleinen tiger nicht da
und wenn ich mich irgendwo in porto muss
jetzt einfach liegen
dann drücke ich da hin und dann oh ich
hab schaden bekommt das natürlich nicht
so gut wie sie einmal ganz kurz in game
ort damit ihr das seht ganz einfach so
machen und da hinten drauf klicken das
sind immer noch weniger als 128 blöcke
deswegen kann ich mich dennoch
teleportieren ich kann ich glaube ich
auch noch da hinten teleportieren so
genau und ihr könnt mich immer hin und
her teleportieren also ihr seht schon
werde ich jetzt die hand meiner hand
habe und ich nehme jetzt hier im blog
und schleudert den weg das sind halt
immer noch ein paar benutzungen wenn ich
allerdings zum beispiel ich hab da
hinten teleportieren gehen halt schon
viel mehr benutzung weg es ist halt mega
krass das gute ist man kann damit jetzt
auch einfach ich könnte jetzt man hier
seinen blog nehmen patienten heran so
fanden blog jetzt gegen seinen flitzer
schmeißen das finde ich halt sogar ich
finde dass es mit das geld an dieser
modifikation dass ich quasi wie so ein
ändern wenn wir die ganze blöcke nehmen
kann einfach auf die blöden verwandten
familie schmeißen kann die alle mega
blöd sind und einfach weg teleportiert
werden kann
das ist irgendwie weiß nicht ich mag das
irgendwie diese komische händchen und ja
diese komische hof attacke konnte ich
euch jetzt nicht zeigen
aber die ganz normale militär von dem
bau nicht weil er irgendwie keine blöcke
hatte die aufnehmen konnte oder so wir
sind doch eher selten attacken den
stream könnt ihr euch eigentlich auch
nicht zeigen aber
am ende halt dieses wo er sich dann
explodiert lassen tun hat wo ich ihn
halt getötet habe und der mir diese
fragmente drucken lassen hat und das ist
hat sich das coolste dass man diese
enders toll hand hat und damit blöcke um
herr schmeißen kann wer ganz cool wenn
man deswegen damit noch so ein bisschen
besser sehen könnte das tech-blog quasi
nun der rechten hand dann angezeigt also
nur hier
damit man noch ein bisschen geradeaus
gucken kann weil sonst wäre ich jetzt
treffen will ist es halt ein bisschen
kaka immer aber sonst kann man sich
damit ganz schön coolen hausbahn
freundlich wird sagen der downloadlink
sind der beschreibung allerdings
funktioniert das ganze nun minecraft 1
punkt 6 punkt 4
deswegen würde ich sagen entweder ihr
date ist minecraft zurück was ja
mittlerweile relativ einfach ist ihr
braucht dafür außerdem auch fortschritte
aber das ist nicht so schwer zu
installieren alles ist mega easy dazu
gibt's 1000 tutorials im internet als
wolf ganz machen und probiert es einfach
mal aus megageil ich weiß nicht ob ich
morgen direkt den nächsten mock hiervon
hochladen also den newton skeleton motto
es ist glaube ich der mob der auch mega
geil ist allem ob sind mega gallien
zugefügt werden vor allem der kripo auch
eigentlich snow golem und mythen zombie
java ist auch chillig aber sonst wenig
sagen wie sie hat schon lange über zehn
minuten oder ich weiß gar nicht ich
glaube wir sind über zehn minuten stand
deswegen was eigentlich ganz gut dass
ich das ganze hier jetzt in mehreren
teilen lassen
und ich würde sagen jetzt kommen wie
immer zum ende einer mod vorstellung
gabler und zwar zum geheimnisvollen
geräusch letztes mal war es dass hier
was ich fallen gelassen hat das hier so
ein kleiner schlüssel von meinem fenster
von schüco ist natürlich und zwar meinte
top schröder ein schlüssel der feld und
das war der erste der das geschrieben
hat das waren nämlich 33 minuten oder so
nachdem das video online war und zwar
hört euch nochmal an
einige dachten dass sein geld gewährt
das haben die meisten gedacht und einige
zuhörer das wohngeld ist doch mega
einfach hinein ist ein schlüssel
naja gut freunde was habe ich denn hier
sonst noch so als geräusch das ist
interessant mal schauen ob mir das
rauskriegt so das wird keiner
rauskriegen denke ich anders einer
rausgehen ist ein echt gut nämlich wir
uns war das hier ist jetzt die mega doof
an das kann ich gar nicht raus kriegen
es ist ein gerät ich gebe euch einen
tipp wo man die hand so machen muss so
ein gerät ist dass der sound wenn das
zusammenstößt das hier also in das einer
rauskriegen echt gut ab naja freund ich
hoffe euch jetzt gefallen so eine art
von mod vorstellen weil sie rechte menge
arbeit sonst wie ich sagen dass eine
bewertung damit euch gefallen hat
schreibt eine kommentare was ihr sonst
noch so für mods sehen wollte natürlich
sagen schaut euch noch wunderschönen tag